bonsoir nouvelle semaine pour le 7 8
votre rendez-vous d'information locale
nous sommes le 9 juillet aujourd'hui
c'est Sylvie Faucheux qui va nous
accompagner bonsoir vous êtes l'ancienne
présidente de l'Université de Versailles
50 ans en Yvelines et la nouvelle
présidente du pôle de recherche et
d'enseignement supérieur des universités
Paris gant ouest vous allez nous
expliquer en quoi cela consiste dans un
instant mais on va tout de même
commencer par les chiffres du
baccalauréat 2012 le taux de réussite
pour les filières générales étant hausse
79,3% des candidats ont obtenu leur
diplôme du premier coup la plus forte
progression par rapport à l'an passé est
à chercher du côté du bac scientifique
plus 2,6%
86,2% déclarés admis dès le premier tour
en revanche du côté des filières
professionnelles filières
professionnelle sont à la traîne 68,8%
seulement d'admissibles une chute de
6,1% par rapport à 2011 les épreuves de
rattrapage se poursuivent jusqu'au 11
juillet mercredi les détails des
résultats par Academy devraient alors
être annoncées Sylvie Faucheux juste
votre regard sur ces chiffres du
baccalauréat ça veut dire que le de vos
progrès ou qu'au contraire le bac est
plus facile à obtenir aujourd'hui je me
prononcerai pas là-dessus ce que
j'espère surtout c'est que c'est tous
ces jeunes vont choisir des orientations
qui vont leur permettre d'avoir une
bonne formation une bonne insertion
professionnelle mais je ne peux pas me
prononcer sur le niveau des des jeunes
qui ensuite à l'université ces jeunes
vous les trouvez plus qualifié moins
qualifié je pense qu'ils sont beaucoup
plus angoissés que par le passé ils ont
parfois des difficultés sur des sur des
matières fondamentales comme le français
bon ça on peut on peut les pleurer mais
en même temps je crois qu'il y a une
volonté et un sérieux qui qui est de
plus en plus important pour rester avec
nous on va parler de vos nouvelles
fonctions présidente du pôle de
recherche et d'enseignement supérieur
des universités Paris Grand Ouest mais
voici déjà le rappel des titres de ce 9
juillet des titres qui seront développés
dans une quinzaine de minutes
dans l'actu aujourd'hui l'Open de France
de golf s'est terminé ce dimanche à
Guyancourt par la victoire d'un Allemand
martial SIM c'est sa deuxième victoire
sur le circuit européen le meilleur
Français Raphaël Jacquelin termine
troisième à deux coups du vainqueur la
guérilla jardinière le nom peut faire
peur en réalité il s'agit pour un
collectif de ce réapproprier l'espace
urbain et d'y ajouter des éléments de
verdure une note de verre au milieu du
béton le soleil tarde à venir et
pourtant il faut penser en cette saison
à prévenir ses yeux des ultraviolets les
conseils d'un ophtalmologiste la seule
protection ce sont les verres solaires
et il faut bien les choisir RTT une
signification qui peut en cacher une
autre RTT comme remettez tong une série
d'animations proposées à
Magny-les-Hameaux troisième édition qui
se termine ce vendredi soir
l'invité de ce 7 8 Sylvie Faucheux donc
la présidente de ce pôle de recherche
qui regroupe les universités de
Versailles Saint-Quentin de
Cergy-Pontoise ainsi qu'une dizaine
d'autres écoles et d'instituts déjà
expliquez-nous à quoi sert ce presse
comme on l'appelle Paul de recherche
supérieur qui a été créé en février
dernier il est tout jeune oui alors en
fait c'est le dernier presse créé en
France parce que en réalité l'ensemble
des régions
cette organisée sous forme de presse
avec un regroupement d'un certain nombre
d'universités et d'écoles pour pouvoir
avoir une visibilité une force de frappe
supplémentaire aussi bien en formation
qu'on recherche et surtout qu'en termes
d'ouverture internationale l'idée c'est
d'harmoniser l'offre de formation aussi
d'éviter la concurrence entre les deux
grosses universités puis les autres
partenaires pas seulement c'est aussi de
créer des nouveautés par exemple
nous venons de nous allons créer pour la
rentrée 2013 un institut d'étude
politique ce qui aurait été impossible
si
université de Versailles 50 ans en
Yvelines ou sol l'université
Cergy-Pontoise l'avait souhaité en
regroupant les forces nous pouvons
ouvrir un institut d'étude possibilité
qui fera partie du réseau des IEP de
provinces nous allons aussi créer un
institut de la création par exemple avec
les trois écoles nationales
d'architecture du paysage de Versailles
et l'École Nationale d'Art de
Cergy-Pontoise donc là vous voyez deux
exemples ou finalement nous pouvons
créer des nouvelles formations donc
ouvrir à tous les jeunes dans notre de
nos territoires aussi bien l'ensemble
des Yvelines que du Val-d'Oise et bien
l'ouvrir de nouvelles formations et leur
éviter finalement d'aller ils sont en
province ou d'aller à Paris donc c'est
aussi des nouveautés de ce type là nous
pouvons gagner des grands projets de
recherche c'était le cas par exemple
avec patrimo dans le cadre du grand
emprunt parce que ensemble nous avons
des complémentarités et puis nous allons
ouvrir aussi
par exemple un Institut Confucius qui va
permettre à l'ensemble de nos étudiants
mais aussi à l'ensemble du monde
socio-économique de nos territoires de
se former aux Chinois à la culture
chinoise et puis de permettre des
partenariats entre les entreprises
françaises qui veulent aller en Chine et
les entreprises chinois qu'est-ce qui
refusent de venir sur nos territoires
donc en fait c'est vraiment pas dans une
dans un optimiser un objectif de de
réduction de coûts comme on pourrait le
penser c'est plutôt dans un objectif
d'accroissement de toute la visibilité
et de toute l'attractivité de
l'enseignement supérieur de la recherche
pour nos territoires et en fait pas de
suppression de poste dans chacune des
universités non chez les partenaires non
je dirais que pour le moment c'est même
plutôt le contraire parce que lorsqu'on
crée un institut d'étude politique il
doit y avoir des nouveaux postes nous
allons ouvrir la fac de médecine donc de
l'Université de Versailles
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines va ouvrir donc
sur l'université de du Pontoise une
première année de médecine donc qui va
permettre à ces étudiants donc de de se
former donc en médecine en payant en
particulier sans être obligé d'aller à
Paris parce qu'il pouvait pas venir chez
nous pour des raisons de transport donc
là c'est avec des postes nouveaux alors
soit qui vont être créés par le mystère
soit sur nos budgets propres soit parce
que nous allons chercher des
financements par projet car je dois dire
que nous avons un très fort soutien de
nos collectivités territoriales en
particulier le Conseil général des
Yvelines qui soutient par exemple
l'Institut d'études politiques mais
aussi la communauté d'agglomération de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines qui est
intéressé par privé aussi qui vont bien
sûr donc dans le presse donc nous avons
dans notre conseil d'administration et
un certain nombre de grands groupes qui
d'oraient déjà fait savoir qui nous
soutiendraient sur des projets donc par
exemple un projet donc sur une chair
industrielle sur la logistique verte un
autre projet là plutôt sur Les Mureaux
dans un institut d'efficacité
énergétique et sur le montoir un
institut de l'éco-construction donc avec
des partenaires à chaque fois privés les
grands groupes industriels et les
collectivités territoriales donc en fait
vous voyez que même pour nos territoires
et bien cela permet de d'accueillir des
nouveaux instituts d'enseignement
supérieur de recherche qui n'avaient pas
et qui vont permettre de développer des
nouvelles formes de collaboration et
aussi de fournir des formations
continues pour des personnes qui
seraient requalification sur ces
thématiques là du côté des étudiants ça
va changer quoi concrètement un diplôme
qui sera plus reconnu aussi peut-être
qu'il y aura plus de poids alors un
diplôme qui sera nécessairement plus
reconnu parce que
porter par je dirais plus de
d'établissement mais aussi surtout des
services nouveaux notamment
international par exemple à
l'international nous allons partir de sa
formation à l'étranger nous allons
ouvrir donc deux bureaux en Chine et
nous allons donc je vous parler d'un
Institut Confucius donc nous sommes en
train de monter des masters donc en
anglais qui seront en fait qui se
réalisent qui seront cohabiter en Chine
ou alors quoi habilités aux États-Unis
donc cela on peut le faire au niveau
d'un presse parce que voilà on a plus de
possibilités plus de moyens pour pouvoir
réaliser ce type de projet donc voilà
les étudiants ça leur offrira plus
d'opportunités aussi beaucoup des
nouvelles formations possibles quand je
dis Institut d'Études Politiques quand
je dis que les étudiants de Cergy
pourront rester sur Cergy pour faire un
pain quand même de médecine
pourront avoir accès à un institut de la
création comme cela existe dans toutes
les grandes universités américaines et
bien c'est offrir à nos étudiants des
parcours supplémentaires et leur ouvrir
en fait des nouvelles perspectives quel
est le défi majeur pour les universités
aujourd'hui parce que l'objectif c'est
d'y répondre alors objectif majeur pour
les universités il y en a plusieurs
c'est un
réussir l'insertion professionnelle
étudiante de
être vraiment
excellent du point de vue de la
recherche pour être alors et on sait
bien que les classements internationaux
sont très critiques mais enfin c'est
quand même un critère et puis 3
l'international car quand même les
universités françaises ont pris du
retard dans l'internationalisation de
leur formation je disais offrir des
parcours complètement en anglais c'est
indispensable si on veut attirer des
étudiants étrangers et simultanément
faire des cohabitations avec des
universités étrangères pour nos
étudiants et puis quatrièmement les
technologies de l'information et de la
communication où nous avons acquis un
fort retard là aussi et donc une des
missions aussi des presse c'est
l'innovation pédagogique et pouvoir
créer des plateformes de formation en
ligne qui vont compléter et soutenir les
étudiants dans leur parcours de
formation quand ça fait effectivement
beaucoup de priorités on va voir si les
Yvelines noires et cinq continents ont
les mêmes priorités qu'elle est
aujourd'hui le grand défi des
universités françaises c'est la question
que nous avons posée
moi j'aime bien comme cela parce que on
est proche des autres universités je
pense que ce serait plus pratique pour
les étudiants comme ça
il y aurait pas des histoires de dossier
à récupérer ou des choses comme ça après
pourquoi pas je pense que ce serait
mieux plus pratique peut-être aussi pour
les étudiants étrangers au niveau de la
taille à l'université non c'est c'est
très bien mais c'est une faille qui est
petite restreinte et on est cocooné ici
c'est familial et du coup les étudiants
enfin moi en tant qu'étudiant je me sens
moins désorienté qu'à la fac de Nanterre
par exemple où j'ai pu faire un semestre
de titularisé pas mal de vacataires
parce que c'est université comme
d'autres universités donc fonctionne
beaucoup sur donc sur des personnels non
titulaires et donc je pense que ça
perturbe mon parti le fonctionnement de
de cette université dans la mesure où la
disponibilité d'un vacataire n'est pas
la même que celle d'un titulaire au
niveau de la mobilité oui ce serait
intéressant quand même que les
universités se mettent d'accord même au
niveau des contenus des formations ou
parfois il y a un décalage total on
reprend des choses quand on change
l'université pour une autre formation et
où en fait on s'ennuie du coup alors on
est perdu parce que c'est carrément
autre chose et que ça correspond pas du
tout à une cohérence davantage entre les
universités et les contenus des
formations
je reviens sur juste une chose qu'on a
entendu tout à l'heure université à
taille humaine en fait c'est un petit
peu le message que l'étudiant de voulait
faire passer une université telle
qu'elle est aujourd'hui en tout cas sur
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines ça reste à
taille humaine
il est objectif c'est pas de tout
fusionner sur un seul endroit ça il y a
un projet à côté qui se subjective là je
suis pas sûr qu'il atteindra l'objectif
c'est justement que chacun reste sur son
territoire et on ne voit même vous le
voyez des formations nouvelles sur des
territoires qui est jusqu'à présent on
peut parler de Saint-Germain en live
parler des Mureaux qui jusqu'à présent
n'avait pas d'enseignement supérieur et
de recherche donc c'est plutôt je dirais
on continue à être sur la taille humaine
et à être fortement ancré sur le
territoire tout en ayant une visibilité
internationale ça veut dire que chacune
des deux universités qui constituent
pour l'instant ce presse ou les autres
partenaires vont garder leur identité
propre alors bien entendu ils vont
garder leur identité propre et leur
pouvoir de décision et leur pouvoir de
décision oui peut-être que à terme mais
ça prend du temps ces choses là
peut-être qu'à terme les mutualisations
se feront de plus en plus et pourquoi
pas
qu'on peut être conformera une seule
grande université mais enfin toujours
est-il que même si c'était le cas on
voit bien que chacun resterait sur les
territoires et je crois aussi que nous
ne sommes pas là l'objectif c'est
d'avancer pas à pas parce qu'on sait
trop que d'obliger par des décisions qui
viendraient d'en haut de tels fusion ça
ne marche pas donc il faut avoir un
presse par projet ce qui est le cas
aujourd'hui et puis les gens apprennent
à travailler ensemble et petit à petit
et bien les rapprochements vont se faire
donc voilà ce sont pas avant d'avoir une
super université peut-être mais une
super université vous savez ça peut être
aussi une grande université confédérale
ou chacun garde son autonomie ça peut
être différente forme mais pour le
moment nous nous sommes pas là et je
crois que il faut on l'a que quelques
mois d'existence quand même et il faut
que chacun s'empare du suffisamment du
projet ce sont suffisamment à l'aise
avec le projet pour savoir ce que dans
10 ans il sera mais pour le moment nous
avons des je pense que vous avez vu des
belles des belles objectifs d'ores et
déjà donc on travaille dans ce cadre là
une dernière question qui concerne
l'actualité politique du moment puisque
Jean-Marc air au Premier ministre lors
de son discours de politique générale
annoncé que le gouvernement allait
réformer la loi sur les universités pour
garantir le bon fonctionnement et
l'autonomie réelle des établissements
d'enseignements supérieurs est-ce que
c'est une bonne ou une mauvaise idée
selon vous bah écoutez je ne sais pas il
va y avoir des assises donc au niveau
national qui vont commencer en octobre
si c'est pour aller vers une réelle
autonomie c'est-à-dire au bout de la loi
d'autonomie comme je l'ai déjà dit il y
a plusieurs reprises je serai évidemment
d'accord puisque cette loi d'autonomie
n'est pas allée jusqu'au bout il y a par
exemple tout ce qui est le patrimoine
qui n'appartient toujours pas aux
universités donc un certain nombre de
choses qui sont restées un peu sur le
bord de chemin donc si on va jusqu'au
bout tant mieux donc maintenant je pense
que les assises vont nous en dire un peu
plus au fil des semaines à partir des
mois d'octobre et puis les assises est
donc la loi de programmation qui sera
présentée au Parlement ce sera au début
de l'année 2013 merci Sylvie fau d'être
venu sur ce plateau nouvelle présidente
du pôle de recherche et d'enseignement
supérieur à des universités Paris dans
l'Ouest merci à vous le 7 8 va se
poursuivre à présent avec un point sur
l'actualité du département le journal
avec Alice Gastine